well before we get started gonna dress
this my last video the Chucky the
child's play review some reason was
stuck at 360 P resolution
it's a 1080p video so if the resolution
of this video stuck at 360 that's simply
YouTube checking out its own esophagus
by having his head so far up its own ass
that said let's review
[Music]
spider-man far from home so spider-man
far from home is the third second
spider-man movie this time it's a sequel
to spider-man homecoming spider-man
wants to go on vacation but as we saw in
the trailer he can't just Nick Fury's
like no no we need your help so Mysterio
is teamed up with Nick Fury a now
spider-man's teamed up with them to take
out some elemental badness or monsters
that are shaped like lava monsters and
water monsters Hydra men though they
don't ever use a name so is it Hydra man
so [ __ ] that threatens the earth you
know common stuff in the MCU these days
what do spider-man wants just be on
vacation with his class who wants to
have a good time but look at that he's
being drawn back into the fight gotta
keep this review very vague that I want
to avoid spoilers so if you feel like
hey this review is [ __ ] it's vague
that's just me try not to spoil anything
for you cuz if I even go off the rails
it's gonna be like so spider-man far
from home I saw it that's set I enjoyed
spider-man far from home I dug this
movie the second half of the movie is
what I really loved and because it's the
second half of the movie it's what the
movie leaves you with so it's easier to
take that home with you and be like oh
great the first half of the movie I was
like it's a cute high school comedy it's
fine
you know but it's not the spider-man
stuff I came for when spider-man does
stuff in the first half of the movie but
didn't feel like a spider-man movie it
was a high school comedy is what it was
he granted spider-man homecoming had
that as well but I like the whole
coming-of-age thing in there though this
is also a coming-of-age story how many
times can you come of age as many times
you can make spider-man movies second
half of the movies really was like okay
here we go into overdrive now you have
your spider-man movie or at least what I
personally wanted in a spider-man movie
look it's like this I played spider-man
on ps4 I'm broken now I now require my
spider-man stories to be at least that
good it's just what happened that said I
love Peter Parker's story in here Tony
Stark just died it's like who's the next
Tony Stark I don't know maybe this new
kid spider-man I would say spoiler alert
for avengers endgame for even saying
that but avengers endgame is the second
highest-grossing film in history if you
were gonna see avengers endgame you've
seen it by now if you haven't seen it by
now you just don't give a [ __ ] to see it
and that really shined in here the
struggle between Peter Parker wanting a
normal life and having to be spider-man
I mean that is what spider-man is I also
love Jake Gyllenhaal in this movie Jake
Gyllenhaal was great he was charismatic
as hell in fact any
I think of a people talking that I
really liked in this movie probably
involves him I heard that like oh he and
Tom Holland have such great chemistry I
mean if they have a couple good scenes
together yeah what people mean when they
say that is Jake Gyllenhaal is the
[ __ ] man and if I'm being honest with
myself I'm gonna let the fanboy flag fly
I just love mysterio he's always been a
personal favorite of mine and I accepted
years ago that would never see a movie
with him in it and the fact that they
have him with me with him in it and it
was done well well shoot it's a summer
Christmas for all of us Quentin Beck
fans I also really liked zendaya in this
movie like in the first one we didn't
know she was MJ or a variant of Mary
Jane and at the end was like oh I'm MJ
and I was like are you though you feel
like a completely different character
but really the spider-man dynamic of
high school has changed he used to be
nerds are outcasts and they're nerdy and
then the jocks like the flash Thompsons
are the jocks and they're the ones who
pick on the Nerds now it's like it's so
different they have to change things up
like flash Thompson's also a nerd one is
in a world where the high school social
dynamic has changed so much since
spider-man's inception plus the
characters in spider-man stories have to
also change and be different and
basically updated to more accurately
represent a modern day high school of
nice person [ __ ] popular kid outcast
and everyone in between
I thought MJ and Peter Parker I thought
the relationship is quite sweet and my
biggest gripe about the movie is some of
the pacing in the first act like if the
movie's a bit too long and I think it
might be anything they could have cut
they could have cut from the first act
of the movie and you could have cut what
I'm gonna call some awkward funny
moments that don't really land but not
most of them because most of them do
land but some of them don't which is my
point it's like you have enough funny
moments why do you need to keep all of
them you can cut some of the more
awkward ones out you still have enough
laughs in here for people to walk out
and be like oh the movie was funny if
that's what you're going for like they
were on set filming they were like we
need something funny to happen what
should we do I got it we'll have the
teacher take a selfie with a
35-millimeter camera and the camera will
drop in the water funny and that kind of
stuff I'm like not the strongest moments
in the movie you shouldn't stand now
it's only a couple times but at a point
is just like the entire dynamic of the
MCU were like alright we're comedies now
you can have the comedy take a back seat
for a good character moment is fine like
the entire Ned Leeds romance in here
like I was like why are you wasting my
time
we're great but it's an MCU movie it's a
summer blockbuster of course the action
scenes are gonna be great this isn't
2002 when Raimi spider-man first came
out like I've never seen something like
that before yeah but we've seen a lot of
things like that before
but what I liked was underneath the hood
of the action spectacle there were
actually some pretty clever cogs turning
I appreciated that couple scenes in
particular that weren't necessarily
action sequences I was like I was really
hoping something like this was in this
movie and it was and it was amazing okay
it's pretty much what I can talk about
without going into spoilers right yes
fantastic
I guess we'll wrap this up I'm gonna say
spider-man far from home it was solid I
think I like spider-man homecoming more
Raimi spider-man 2 I like more and
although the first half dragged on more
than the second half in leaving the
movie theater great post-credit scenes
as well I walked out going yeah they
left me with a good taste of my mouth
and a smile on my face
mmm yep I'm gonna address it I hope that
awkward moment when sang it out loud
hearing me say it it sounded dirtier
than it did in my mind it's not gonna go
whatever I'm not cutting it out it stays
cuz I meant it I'll say spider-man far
from home is worth watching and worth
buying on blu-ray
right so spider-man far from home have
you seen it what you think about it or
what is your favorite spider-man villain
that's yet to be on screen burnin on
Kraven the hunter cuz he's pretty
[ __ ] bust let's be rip but you choose
yours whoever it is whoever you think
comment below let me know and yes once
again if you like this video if you can
click that like button it does help me
out absolutely I do notice it and I do
appreciate it we're gonna take the
algorithm back for ourselves what I'm
sorry so I genuinely do appreciate your
help thank you and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]